for entrepreneurs as smart as you are on
day one all you have is a faith-based
enterprise it's a religious organization
because you're betting on your vision
and your in you see things others don't
but you know we now know over history
about 95 percent of the time you don't
have a vision you're actually
hallucinating so is it possible to kind
of eliminate that waste of time and
energy to find out only later that you
were wrong and so what we propose is you
take your hypotheses you can actually
break down your vision into this
business model canvas and now get out of
the building in a fairly formal way
using something we call the customer
development process to test every one of
those hypotheses and what we'll find is
you know what as smart as we were were
not smarter than the collective
intelligence of our customers well big
idea and when we find out that perhaps
were wrong
we either iterate that is make minor
changes or we do something called a
pivot which is defined as a pivot is a
substantive change to one or more of the
business model canvas components and
instead of firing executives or running
out of money or building the wrong
product we simply iterate or pivot until
we converge on a repeatable and scalable
business model